yeah would you survive the zombie
apocalypse survive the zombie we've
discussed it so many times really the
conclusion we came to what what position
would you be in the zombie apocalypse
like what you what would the stereotype
what what stereotype would you fall
under I'll just be the one cuz if I
learn anything from zom movies or
whatever it's just like oh the real
danger we see other people all along and
it's like yeah I'll just stay away from
other people l so you'd be like the one
you got to talk to people you need to no
well we have to stick together why
because what if you I have all the
provisions
okay what is this an OC where you have
everything you ever need my head have it
on odds are you play too much Dead
Rising odds are you got some [__]
poopy diapers and some some cans of food
and you got nothing you're in Japan we
got no weapons we're done I'll throw my
[__] at the zombies that'll stop them
God final inconvenience the zomb oh oh
Jesus [__] I have the samurai swords SL
through where are you getting that you
do you own a samurai S I will not
disclose you definitely do let's see
what happens he's he's already prepping
don't test
me right [__] would that be a weapon of
choice samurai sword in Japan yeah
that's the dream he follows the code of
BU Kill the Zombies finally he just
chops him cleans the blood it's like
finally an excuse to pull this
out
I can live out my wee dream you know
that would happen like around here oh
yeah if it breaks out in Japan it' be so
sick prime location what do you mean
Prime for what we like Su blossoms and
oh my God zombies nothing beats nothing
beats killing zombies under the cherry
blossoms I'll tell you that
fellas double points for the Aesthetics
oh my Lord everything is better in
Japan zombie apocalypse zombie
apocalypse zombie apocalypse from
[Laughter]
Japan okay they always ding games come
on you know what I mean okay there's got
to be some there's got to be something
this thep of guy like chop down a zombie
and then do
the H
yeah what were you saying Sor there's
got to be something there's got to be
something that is not better in Japan or
is that Banks yeah Banks objectively I
guess zombie apocalypse fixes the bad
things about Japan true work life
balance gone uh Town Hall Banks gone all
bad things so I guess maybe a zomie
apocalypse is what we
need that then we know for real then
won't really know truly the best that is
true that is true I'm trying to think is
there is there any other like famous
apocalypse types out there or is it only
just like zombie apocalypse I guess like
nuclear maybe
oror metor were done none none of them
are all done yeah none of them are like
fun to survive there's no chance of
those there's no chance you know what
about like a Long Winter like a winter
That Never Ends o that' be fun that's
not fun I feel like even just Co was bad
enough I'm like [__] there's out a no
toilet I think winter if everywhere was
like blizzarding we'd be done everyone
would die very s quickly you think so in
Japan yeah because like I don't think
you if it was constantly blizzarding I I
don't think you'd be able to keep the
roads clean yeah but I feel like Japan
that's that's the big issue yeah because
how can you how can you transport food
how can you how can you grow food uh
well that too but we we have we have a
lot of canned food that'll last a while
right we got Japan would figure it out
like all right guys um everyone has to
take turns sacrificing their body uh for
cannibalism so you can buy this bag of
rice for uh two cup ramens like that'll
be the new that'll be the new you know
prison cup Ramen Ramen is currency in
prisons right yeah so I guess Japan will
become prison will be rich
yes we'll finally be the another better
thing oh my Lord if a meteor strikes
would we all die yeah yeah but surely
some people live well depends on the
size of the meteor people have bunkers
and [__] right yeah people in bunkers
would live so okay yeah you go no but
like you no but the medeor depends where
it hit like if the if a direct I get
that but I just mean like okay let's say
where is all Humanity gone like no I
think it's really hard to get rid of all
of humanties two to wipe out Mo to wipe
out most of humanity is technically like
easy but to wipe out all Humanity will
take a lot of effort because some way
somehow some people can Sur we all like
cockroaches yeah I'm not going to
die what makes say that well it seems
like you guys are giving up so I'll take
the opportunity to not die
yeah our life force doesn't go into you
Felix that's not how it works I don't
know maybe it
does like Goku you said some people
would live and you all gave up so I'll
get okay first of all I didn't give up I
said we died cuz of [__] media giving
up we're not giving up I'm dead cuz a
giant space Rock a hole in the ground
I'll be prepared what you okay yeah
that's a question would you try and
survive like during that kind of
Apocalypse it' be
fun I would yeah be kind of I would
describe it as f i okay I would honestly
Rish at the chance that my only [__]
thing I have to worry about is getting
food and water it's kind of nice yeah
but that's all I got to
do I I don't I don't got to do taxes I
don't got to I don't got to worry about
like am I late for a meeting like I I
just all I have to do is just be like
get food get water good I actually
thought about that for a cuz I you ever
had those weeks where it's like too much
paperwork too much taxes too much
[__] let's just go to the woods can
I just like go to prison so I'm free
from
all that's cuz you're Swedish that's how
bad Swedish prisons are just
different yeah yeah you got the Swedish
prison Outlook that's not
fair I'm going just steal this bread
real quick to get a vacation
yeah jaese person that make you work
like eight hours a day yeah the manly
Earth should drop everything you're
doing and just build a cabin in the
woods C in the woods would be hype that
would be hype wood would be sick yeah I
would love that I don't know I feel like
it depends on how bad the apocalypse is
if it's not fun then I'm like why what's
the point of surviving Che the first huh
you're checking the vi yeah checking the
vibe first you know if if I'm like if
I'm like in a zombie apocalypse and I'm
like I'm [__] kidding my zombie
parents or zombie friends I'm like no
you there's like a convention for
bunkers in a bunker that definitely is
and there a bunch of like bunker people
who survive and they're like yeah this
is say apocalypse C they're in a bunker
yeah might be they're probably in NADA
there that'd be lame I wouldn't want to
be bunker
boy where would you be in the top of a
tree or something yeah top of a tree top
of a tree tree he said the tree I just
said yes he didn't have to this is why
you won't survive you're listening
you're like a sheep yeah you're not
thinking for
yourself what would be the prime
location Australia no Japan we
established this come on the cherry
blossom and the
samur I would sit patiently what does
the cherry blossom add to your survival
aesthetic just just makes you feel I
would sit patiently at the bottom of a
sakro tree with my kater in my hand
waiting for my next victim anemy an
enemy comes up behind you oh I
see dead before I draw my
sword
I feel like life would be greatly
improved if we did have that aura
[__] they have an anime they're like
ah I sensed your aura what you know an
anime when they're like I can oh yes
yeah I feel like life would be so much
cooler if we all had
Aura I feel like we do have Aura though
we don't [__] have Aura G people have
Aura we have Vibes like Ora like you
walk in a building's the difference
what's the difference like I can tell
your strength level you walk into a
building I'm like ah a worthy opponent
stepped into this building bro I I sat
next to Lady beard for 2 hours people
definitely have [__] that's not Ora
that's volume that was just that was
loud it's an auditory Aura like a
tangible aura that we can feel and look
at and measure what you want out of all
things well have you never felt that
when like say like someone who's like
really really famous is in the same room
as you no it's cuz they or weaker than
[Music]
mine so you do believe in the AA no but
but if I no but if I did though it mine
would be bigger or if someone like you
really respect or like really really
like for instance is like that's your
brain doing funny little tricks on
yourself is that not what the [__]
all no or I'm I'm talking about a
tangible real thing oh like something
you can see no no I guess maybe we could
see it I don't know but like you can
like actually like someone walks behind
you like anime you're like ah yeah I
sense him his his power has is become my
vicinity be want anime to be real yeah I
guess what I'm asking is it too hard to
ask like I just want
nen I feel like other people
already in my space too much all right I
don't want to or you you guys been
footsy in the whole [__] episode what
are you talking about well that's
love that's that's a different time of
world